18:30 Uhr:
Dienstbeginn auf der Rettungswache.
Tobias Filler ist angehender Notfallsanitäter.
Vor ihm und seinem Ausbildungsleiter
Marcus Müller liegt eine 12-stündige Schicht.
Mit dabei: ein Pfefferspray
– offiziell zur Tierabwehr.
Heute ist Samstag – keine beliebte Schicht.
Also, am Wochenende
fährt man nachts meistens mehr,
weil die ... weil die Leute
am Wochenende gerne feiern gehen.
Mit dem Alkoholpegel
steigt auch das Risiko für Übergriffe.
Unterwegs.
Die Nachricht über Funk:
bewusstlose Frau vor einem Supermarkt.
Mehr Informationen gibt es selten.
Eine Wahl haben die Rettungssanitäter nicht.
Wir nehmen erst mal nur das EKG noch mit.
Die Patientin kauert am Boden.
Ihr Begleiter hat
offensichtlich Drogen genommen.
Ihm geht alles viel zu langsam.
Jetzt lassen Sie ... lassen Sie mich doch erst
mal mit ihr sprechen,
ja, damit ich überhaupt erst mal
mit ihr reden kann,
und dann gehen wir zusammen ins Auto.
Und da sind wir ein bisschen ...
haben wir ein bisschen mehr Ruhe
und dann können wir miteinander sprechen.
In Seminaren haben die Notfallhelfer gelernt,
wie man deeskaliert.
Auch das Zurückziehen in den
Rettungswagen ist eine bewusste Strategie.
Lassen Sie uns doch erst mal ...
erst mal reden wir.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben doch jetzt uns gerufen
und jetzt müssen wir doch erst mal
miteinander reden können.
Dass auch ein Routineeinsatz
schnell eskalieren kann,
hat Tobias Filler selbst erlebt.
Vor eineinhalb Jahren wurden sie zum
Bahnhof gerufen: ein bewusstloser Mann.
Als der Patient zu sich kam,
griff er sie an.
Bei dem Übergriff fiel Tobias Filler
fast auf die Gleise.
Wie nah er dem Tod war,
begriff er erst später.
So nach ‘nem halben, Dreivierteljahr
kamen diese Bilder wirklich wieder hoch –
was da so passiert ist,
und dann war ich fünf Wochen
auch erst mal nicht im Dienst.
Man hat gemerkt,
dass man nicht mehr schlafen kann.
Wenn man geschlafen hat,
dann kamen genau diese Bilder wieder hoch.
Dass sich die Übergriffe häufen,
hat mit einer neuen
Erwartungshaltung zu tun.
Man ruft den Rettungsdienst und
die haben das zu tun, was wir möchten.
Und wenn das nicht so gemacht wird,
wie die Menschen,
die uns ein Hilfeersuchen entgegenbringen ...
wenn wir das nicht so tun,
dann kann das auch relativ schnell
in Gewalt umschlagen oder Aggression.
Der nächste Einsatz: sechs Polizisten gegen
einen Mann im Drogenrausch.
... vom Balkon runtergefallen.
Also, von dem ersten oder von dem ...?
Vom ersten. Er hat Verletzungen aufgrund
von vermutlich Glasscherben ...
gesprungen, gefallen ...
Blutet er irgendwie stark?
Ja.
Der Mann hatte Möbel aus dem Fenster
geworfen.
Als die Polizei eintraf,
sprang er hinterher.
Ecstasy oder Kokain,
vermuten die Einsatzkräfte.
Momentan ist er noch extrem aggressiv. Er ist
durch die Polizei mit Handfesseln gefesselt.
Hier durch. Hey!
Der Patient hört nicht auf, die Einsatzkräfte zu
bespucken.
Hey, Junge!
Jetzt bleib doch mal ganz ruhig. Alles ist gut.
Wir wollen dir doch nur helfen, ja?
Alles ist gut.
Keiner will dir irgendwas tun.
Transport in die Notaufnahme:
Die Polizisten fahren mit.
Okay?
Ja.
Ohne Polizei wäre Marcus Müller
alleine mit dem Patienten.
Alles schon parat,
die warten nur auf euch.
Alles verstanden.
Vielen Dank!
Nach zehn Stunden Dienst:
Zeit für einen Kaffee.
Privat ist Marcus Müller Kampfsportler.
Die Kollegen fragen ihn im Scherz,
warum er nicht eingriff.
Das ist nicht unser Job.
Dafür gibt’s die Polizei.
Deswegen ist es oft mal so,
dass die Kollegen
sich relativ viel gefallen lassen,
bis die Polizei hinzugeholt wird
oder auch bis man sich verteidigt,
weil die Hemmschwelle von unseren
Mitarbeitern doch da sehr hoch ist.
Sieben Uhr morgens:
Schichtende.
Angespuckt, bepöbelt und bedroht –
doch die 112 glänzt.